no no I don't think we could talk about
the Caribbean without mentioning the
Dominican Republic it's a major tourist
destination with the largest economy and
even the highest mountain in all of the
island countries in the Caribbean the
Dominican Republic is a very very
special place in Latin America and I'm
not only saying this because we can find
amazing places such as Punta Cana by IB
or Puerto Plata here among many many
others I'm also saying it because this
was the very first place where
Christopher Columbus's men settled when
America was discovered in 1492 yep it's
true for good or ill everything started
here this is where at in America as we
know it began
[Music]
it's capital at Santo Domingo was the
first modern city on the entire American
continent here the first Cathedral the
first University in the first hospital
were built but yes it's true if we
associate the Dominican Republic with
anything it's gonna be tourism
[Music]
the Sun Revolution
this is by far the country's best face
and not for nothing folks the Dominican
Republic it's trendy thanks to its 1,000
miles of coastline more than 250 miles
of amazing Caribbean beaches its golf
courses and huge all-inclusive resorts
the country is experiencing an
impressive tourist famine of course this
story has been developing for a while
see during the 1940s the then
plenipotentiary dictator of the islands
general Rafael Trujillo gave the order
to encourage tourism this was probably
done with the intention of filling his
pockets
that's how the malecon de Santa Domingo
in the first luxury hotel in the city
the hotel Jara WA opens in 1940 four
years later in 1968 the first
legislation that considered tourism
development to be of national interest
was approved so as you can see an
emphasis on tourism not exactly new but
[Music]
in recent years it has completely taken
off in 2017 the Dominican Republic a
country with just over ten million
inhabitants managed to attract more than
7 million tourists
it grew so quickly that the country is
expected to overcome the ten million
international tourists barrier in no
more than three years and of course as
you can imagine all of this
it's got consequences in the last five
years foreign direct investment in the
tourism sector has grown by more than
five hundred percent it's multiplied by
six times nowadays the Dominican
Republic is more than 80 thousand hotel
rooms and this number it just doesn't
stop growing
to give you an idea to accommodate all
these visitors in 2017 Dominican Hotels
opened eight thousand three hundred and
sixty-six new rooms and an additional
fifteen thousand are under construction
Danny lo Medina president of the
Dominican Republic the result tourism is
already the islands main economic
activity and if we take both the wealth
this generates directly and indirectly
into account it means that one out of
every four pesos generated by the
economy from tourism we could say that
the Dominican Republic has discovered
and is beginning to exploit its peculiar
type of oil and the truth is that in
this area it's almost all good news
check out one of their latest
achievements which happened in exchange
for breaking with Taiwan the People's
Republic of China is opening up to
Dominican tourism the Chinese
authorities have declared the Dominican
Republic a tourist destination for all
its citizens of course just a moment
because that's not it folks the
Dominican Republic it's got a different
face because here in this country
we can find a lot of lights but we can
also find a lot of shadows that we
commonly see today in Latin America so
let's take a look at that
[Music]
the other face
the Dominican Republic has achieved one
of the highest growth rates in Latin
America and the Caribbean in the last 25
years the strong performances actually
meant achieving a higher purchasing
power pariah T as well as one of the 10
highest per capita incomes in all of
Latin America at almost $17,000 the
Dominican Republic is paired with Costa
Rica and well above countries such as
Peru Colombia or Ecuador but hold on a
second because that's not the whole
story in spite of everything 32% of all
Dominicans that is one in every three
people live below the poverty line the
average life expectancy barely exceeds
70 and infant mortality is almost 5
times higher than in developed countries
that may explain why we can find one and
a half million Dominicans in the United
States and why after tourism remittances
are the second largest source of wealth
but having said that I think the
question we can all ask ourselves is
well how can such a paradise not take
off
[Music]
well folks the answer is that this
Caribbean land has many of the evils
that unfortunately are all over Latin
America the continents modern history it
began here in 1492
now 526 years later we can find a good
reflection of the best and worst in
Latin America in this exact same place
but delving into this matter the first
great point of darkness we can find is
the stubborn persistence in keeping
policies that have repeatedly been shown
not to work an issue that seems to reign
in this region of the world for example
in matters of informal work irregular
employment which is a serious problem
that has spread throughout the region
see the workers who are exposed to the
situation to informality welcomes a more
precarious conditions with greater
instability as well as having problems
obtaining financing whether that's to
buy a house invest in a business or
properly educate their children and of
course they have lower wages I mean this
is pretty obvious because the company
will invest less money in an employee
who's hired irregularly but this is also
a problem for the government for example
when it comes to collect taxes
[Music]
when in the dominican republic informal
employment effects six out of every ten
workers in this country denominator it's
not decreasing it's growing in 2017 for
example for more jobs were only created
in the public sector and well what does
this info tell us while this is that
formal hiring involves many barriers and
many burdens these can be bureaucracy
taxes outdated regulations these
basically mean that people have to set
up and pay taxes before they even make a
single dollar and all that logically
makes it difficult for private economies
to create quality jobs so with this data
in hand I think it would make sense to
say well heck we need a boost in formal
hiring well what's not working but
unfortunately it doesn't work like that
the same goes for commercial policy you
see in a country with a small local
markets as is precisely the Dominican
Republic's case the foreign sector is
absolutely essential this seems pretty
obvious right well in this country we
can basically find two different
situations
on the one hand there's the free zones
where the company's installed have
favorable conditions both regulatory and
fiscal which they provide in exchange
for basically only working in exports
worth meeting a certain criteria and
being approved by the government on the
other hand there are RV more normal
companies which they're the vast
majority well more than half of all
exports come from the free zones and
additionally in recent years exports
from these places have grown on average
five percent every year
but exports from common Dominican
companies well well check this out
[Music]
so upon seeing this the question I ask
myself is if the free zones work well
why not extend their benefits to the
rest of the country so that Dominican
companies can become more competitive
well unfortunately that's not gonna
happen either but then there's the
issues of the deficit public spending
and debts which in spite of the great
number of bad experiences continues to
be a vice of many Latin American
countries here the Dominican Republic is
also not an exception since 1990 public
spending in the Dominican Republic is
multiplied by 18 here public deficit
it's almost a tradition now just hold on
for a moment because you might be
wondering now well Simon are we talking
about a country that's coming out of
poverty I mean there's lots to do
there's infrastructure that needs to be
created there's ports airports roads
they all need to be built so that this
country can grow but you know what type
of expenditure grows this the most and
no it's not public investments it's
actually current expenditure which is
multiplied by almost 30 since 1990 and
of course expenses have to be paid
partly with more taxes which slows down
the creation of formal jobs and
investments and well partly with desk
check out what's happening with the
Dominican debts with the debts and
interest because of course debts that's
interest
[Music]
indeed almost 1/4 of government or
spending goes towards paying interest
that's the third largest figure in all
of Latin America and it won't stop
growing while despite the tourism
sectors take off this constant
stubbornness with policies that don't
work explains why Dominicans have so
many problems and why there is still so
much poverty in this country I mean
check out how this country ranks in the
global competitiveness index
[Music]
but what about politicians are they
involved in other things and listen up
because the shadows they don't end here
there's a lot more
[Music]
suspicions
folks the Dominican Republic is a
fantastic country and it probably has a
promising future and when it manages to
take that big step it really will be
like a paradise think about it good
weather good beaches and money who could
possibly resist however today the
Dominican Republic has two other very
important problems that may be stopping
the country from taking orphans one of
those is corruption the Dominican
Republic is among the 50 most corrupt
countries according to Transparency
International yeah that right the
Dominican Republic is considered one of
the most corrupt countries in the world
according to Transparency
International's ranking only Venezuela
Haiti Guatemala and Nicaragua are in a
worse situation in Latin America here
corruption at all levels is very common
suspects range from the current
socialist president Danilo Medina who is
accused of having financed his electoral
campaign with bribes to the police
themselves in fact it was in the
Dominican Republic that the construction
company Odebrecht installed its
Coordination Center for the bribes that
it paid internationally in exchange for
contracts and of course many of these
bribes remains there almost 100 million
dollars as far as we know these were
received by politicians and officials in
exchange for concessions work awards and
public contracts
[Music]
but unfortunately that's not all the
other problem which is growing is drug
trafficking the Dominican Republic is
considered one of the most important
bridge countries and narcotics
distribution centers by the United
States drug traffickers have a problem
exporting drugs from Venezuela there are
few commercial flights little container
shipping no tourists and a collapsed
fishing sector but the Dominican
Republic 1,400 kilometers away has it
all in fact according to the DEA and the
European intelligence services nowadays
the Dominican Republic is one of the
main transit countries for narcotics
that go to the United States and the
most frequent for cocaine shipments
coming to Europe and of course this is
an important issue but that's something
we're going to talk about another day in
any case dear viewer let's be absolutely
clear there are problems that
unfortunately are common in the entire
region the Dominican Republic has
achieved a lot in recent decades it's
certainly a fantastic place and it has a
promising future in this video we just
wanted to show you some of the reasons
why this country is not doing as well as
it should so I really hope you enjoyed
this video please do hit that like
button if you did and don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos also
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider Media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine also this channel it's
made possible because of patreon man's
our patrons on patreon please consider
joining them and supporting our mission
of providing independent political
coverage and as always I'll see you in
the next video
[Music]